All right, so I wanted to stop by
little manic episode of cleaning and organizing
to answer this question,
because I don't think I've ever
actually talked about my experience with having ADHD.
Um, medication,
not medication,
etc. So I was diagnosed at,
I believe, 8 years old.
I was in third grade,
because my mom worked in the medical field
and kind of had, like,
behavioral health kids,
behavioral health as, like,
a niche focus of her medical career.
So I think I got diagnosed
earlier than most people around my age.
When I got diagnosed,
I was diagnosed with ADHD,
which is attention deficit hyperactivity disorder.
And I immediately started going through
and trying every drug that they had out.
At one point,
I was on Adderall,
I was on Concerta,
I was on Vyvanse when that came out.
I was on short acting,
I was on time release.
And all of that was great. Honestly,
I don't think I would have graduated college without it.
But. And here is like,
a big trigger warning or, like,
just take this with a grain of salt.
This is my personal experience.
This is not to say anything about
medication versus no medication.
This isn't supposed to sway anyone one way or the other.
This is just what happened to me and what works for me.
First of all,
I developed, um,
heart palpitations and an irregular heartbeat
in my later teens.
I wanna say,
like, 19. So much so,
That I had to wear heart monitor for about a month
just to like,
check everything,
make sure everything was fine.
It was fine.
But being on stimulant
since you're 8,
every single day, like,
maybe not spectacular for, like,
all the body parts.
So after college,
I was working in kitchens
and I was working 12 hour shifts.
I would take my adderall, I,
you know, I would take.
I think at that point
I was on 40 milligrams of Tymerlese,
five amps. And
to be honest,
it was too much.
But I had moved away from my doctor.
I didn't wanna get a new doctor.
I had really shitty health insurance.
I was young,
and my husband,
who, like, is a wonderful,
wonderful man,
but, like, has no experience with neuro divergence,
was like, why don't you just try being off of it?
Because I wouldn't take it on my days off.
And my personality was completely different
on it versus off of it.
Hence why I think
I was over medicated,
because it shouldn't change you in,
in that way.
So when I switched from working,
like, line cook work
to catering,
and I could make kind of my own schedule
of my own hours
a little bit more,
I got off of all my medication.
And really shortly after that,
I became pregnant.
And I didn't wanna go back on any stimulants
or any medication
while I was pregnant
or breastfeeding. And. Haha,
had a second Baby
really close together with my first.
So I went from breastfeeding to another pregnancy.
So when all that was said and done,
there was like
five years later
and I had just become accustomed to not being on it.
And I was also dealing with other mental health issues
which. Sorry,
this is really long winded.
I developed, um,
postpartum anxiety
and I think
a little bit of postpartum OCD.
So it kind of counterbalanced my ADD
because instead of being, um,
neurotically,
like, manic and then,
and then lethargic and overstimulated,
I was just OCD
for the first time in my life.
And I was like, oh,
I got all this together.
No, it was mental illness.
Fast forward to now.
Um, I'm fully over being postpartum with my last baby.
And I have noticed that when I'm driving,
when I'm listening my kids, I'm like.
I literally noticed I was driving
and not paying attention to driving
because I was so distracted with my thoughts and like,
my, like, musings,
and that made me nervous.
I also feel like my ability to like,
be present is really difficult because of my ADD, ADHD.
Um, and so is the overstimulation.
And I feel like I was missing out on things
with my kids.
I wasn't able to, like,
calm the noise and just be.
So I am back on medication.
Um, this is very new for me.
I'm starting with, like,
really, really,
really low doses
because my Biggest fear is getting to a point of, like,
aggressive over prescription again.
And I've Learned my body a lot better
now that I'm an adult
and I don't have another adult telling me
what's right for me.
I can make my decisions on my own
and what dosages, um,
are affecting me in which way.
And I'm much more in tune with my body.
So I'll keep y'all updated on how medicated Lisa
in adulthood goes.